Have you heard of high dose melatonin instead of an aerobatic inhibitor?
I think that's not a winter protocol. No, you could use high dose melatonin too.
That's, you know, I think I have a blog post about it. I would certainly write about that in my book
using it anywhere between 60 to 200 milligrams of melatonin
before that. Normally, if you're trying to get to sleep, you're taking three milligrams of melatonin. So
60 to 200 milligrams is very high dose melatonin. It doesn't help you get to sleep any better,
but it still will give you some of that advantage about the same advantages, three to six milligrams
well. But it works on different systems and it can help with different cancers, not just breast
cancer, not just hormone-revented cancer. Have you heard of bitter melatonin?
I've heard that they use it extensively in Vietnam for breast cancer. Yes, I have.
I don't think I included that in my book, and I don't think I have written a blog post about that.
But yes, I've heard of using bitter melatonin. It's actually in, I'm pretty sure it's in some supplements
that we use. I could be involved though. But yeah, that's another
nutrient that I look at. So I know bitter melatonin isn't herb that is used for decreasing sugar.
So it's in some of our supplements that we use to help people with diabetes, but we don't have it
as a separate supplement.